THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE FOR
US.
AS MENTIONED THIS HAS BEEN A
VERY DIFFICULT DAY FOR THE FOX
NEWS FAMILY BECAUSE TWO OF OUR
CO-WORKERS HAVE DIED IN UKRAINE.
CAMERAMAN PIERRE AND JOURNALIST
AND TRANSLATOR ALEXANDRA
KUVSHYNOVA THEY WERE WORKING
WITH CORRESPONDENT BENJAMIN HALL
OUTSIDE OF KYIV WHEN FIRE HIT
THEIR VEHICLE.
BEN WAS SERIOUSLY WOUNDED AND IN
THE HOSPITAL.
PIERRE AND SASHA DID NOT
SURVIVE.
PIERRE LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE
MICHELLE AND A LOVING FAMILY AND
A LOT OF COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
ABSOLUTELY HEART BROKEN AT THE
LOSS OF A LEGEND PIERRE HAS BEEN
WITH FOX FOR YEARS IN AND OUT OF
WAR ZONES.
>> ON THE RUN THE GUNMEN ARE
COMING CLOSER, PIERRE, GRANT
STICKS.
>> BEFORE UKRAINE PIERRE WAS ON
THE GROUND IN IRAQ, IN
AFGHANISTAN, IN SYRIA.
HE COVERED CONFLICTS BETWEEN
COUNTRIES AND HELPED US REPORT
FROM THE MIDDLE OF RIOTS.
PIERRE WAS A STEADY PRESENCE IN
UNCERTAIN TIMES.
WHEN A CORRESPONDENT OR PRODUCER
ARRIVED AND SAW PIERRE WAITING
FOR THEM, THEY KNEW THEY WERE IN
GOOD HANDS.
BECAUSE HE COULD DO JUST ABOUT
ANYTHING.
HE SHOT VIDEO, FIXED EQUIPMENT,
PRODUCED STORIES, AND EDITED
PIECES ON THE FLY.
PIERRE ALSO SEEMED TO ALWAYS
KNOW THE BACKGROUND OF EVERY
LOCATION.
EVERY STORY.
AND HE HAD AN EXTRAORDINARY
ABILITY TO DO HIS WORK UNDER
INCREDIBLE PRESSURE AND WITHOUT
SLEEP.
SOME OF OUR CORRESPONDENTS WHO
WORKED CLOSELY WITH HIM FEEL
THIS LOSS ESPECIALLY HARD.
TODAY TREY YINGST POSTED THIS
PHOTO WITH PIERRE SAID HE WAS AS
GOOD AS THEY COME.
SELFLESS, BRAVE, PASSIONATE.
JONATHAN HUNT SAYS HE HAS NEVER
FORGOTTEN THE SMILE AND WELCOME
HE RECEIVED FROM PIERRE IN 2003
WHEN HE FIRST AFLID BAGHDAD.
HE SAYS PIERRE MADE EVERYONE A
BETTER JOURNALIST AND A BETTER
PERSON.
KELLOGG SAYS PIERRE WAS WARM AND
GENEROUS WITH HIS TIME AND HE
WAS A RARE BREED OF WAR REPORTER
WHO NEVER GOT JADED.
GREG PALKOT SAYS HE AND PIERRE
WERE EMBEDDED WITH A MARINE
COMPANY DURING IRAQ'S BATTLE OF
FALLUJAH.
HE SAYS THAT PIERRE SAVED HIS
LIFE ON MANY OCCASIONS OVER THE
YEARS HE ADDS THAT PIERRE HATED
SITTING AROUND THE NEWSROOM.
HE WANTED TO BE OUT CHASING THE
STORY.
AND GREG NOTED THAT EVEN WHEN
THE WORST WAS HAPPENING, PIERRE
WOULD REPEAT HIS FAVORITE ADVICE
TO KEEP ON SMILING.
AND THAT OBVIOUSLY IS A LOT
TOUGHER TODAY BECAUSE WE LOST
NOT ONLY A COLLEAGUE BUT A
MENTOR, A LEADER, AND A
WONDERFUL FRIEND.
WE OFFER OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
TO ALL WHO KNEW PIERRE AND ALL
WHO LOVED HIM.
PIERRE ZARKRZEWSKI WAS JUST 50
YEARS OLD.
SASHA AS SHE IS KNOWN WAS JUST
24 YEARS OLD.
SHE WAS SERVING AS A CONSULTANT.
HELPING OUR TEAMS NAVIGATE THE
CITY.
GATHERED NEWS, SPEAK WITH
SOURCES.
OUR CORRESPONDENTS AND PRODUCERS
SAY SHE WAS HARD-WORKIN